Let's talk about John Bolton briefly. There
are multiple new reports out that Donald Trump
is keeping a list of people who crossed him
during his presidency who he would like to
get locked up eventually and his own former
national security advisor. John Bolton is
reportedly on that list. We heard this from
Rick Wilson. We've had Rick on the show, longtime
Republican strategist. He's an anti-Trump
Republican. He says that Donald Trump is likely
to start putting pressure on the justice department
to try to get revenge on people like Bolton
Bolton of course, recently saying that in
his upcoming book, in the manuscript portion
that was released says that Donald Trump personally
told him withhold the Ukraine aid until Ukraine
smears Joe Biden publicly.
Of course, the Senate is expected to vote
to equip Donald Trump tomorrow Wednesday in
the Senate. Rick Wilson says that John Bolton
has one choice right now and that John Bolton
must leak the full manuscript of the book
today. The reason Wilson says this is that
if Bolton doesn't leak the full transcript
with additional context and assertions related
to what Trump told him about Ukraine. Trump
gets acquitted tomorrow and then ruins Bolton's
life. Wilson says, Bolton's only shot is to
try to get the full story out today of what
he saw. Trump do get it into the public before
the Senate votes to make the vote look like
a sham kangaroo court vote, which of course
is exactly what that vote will be. Investigative
reporter Gabriel Sherman says, it's not just
Bolton on Trump's enemies list. It's Republicans
and Democrats. Adam Schiff is on Trump's list.
Jerry Nadler is on Trump's Lift's list.
Even Republican Senator Mitt Romney from new
Utah is reportedly on that list. I can imagine
this list of enemies written in crayon on
a napkin from Kentucky fried chicken that
Trump was eating on air force one, but it
doesn't matter because this is a dystopian
reality. A Sherman reports that he was told
Trump wants John Bolton criminally investigated.
Uh, one possibility would be for the mishandling
of classified information that Trump seems
to think John Bolton was engaged in, which
is truly even if true call the PO caught pot
calling the kettle black when you were Donald
Trump talking about miss handling sensitive
information. There's another report that Trump
wants to leak emails showing that Bolton was
doing pay to play while on the national security
council that's been denied by people close
to Bolton. If this happens, the transition
to full blown authoritarian dictatorship will
be complete. The attempted jailing of former
elected officials and of, uh, administration
officials on trumped up charges as directed
by the president.
Now this is a good opportunity to clarify
something. We need elected officials held
more accountable than they are held. I have
no problem with elected officials current
and former being investigated as part of a
fair judicial process. We lack that. We have
this de facto immunity that so many of our
elected officials and our elites have merely
because they are in a position of power. But
you don't do it by having the president make
a list of enemies that wants a, that he wants
revenge on and then forcing the justice department
to investigate them. Uh, this is exactly why
though I'm saying there have been no consequences
for Donald Trump's actions. So why wouldn't
he do this? Russia probe possible cognitive
decline, hush money payments, campaign finance
violations, hiding his taxes, emoluments violations,
and he's fine. He's continuing to be president.
He's making the U S a laughing stock.
Why wouldn't he be emboldened by that and
say, Hey, let me make a list of enemies and
I'll try to get them jailed sometime soon
because he's gotten away with everything so
far and unless we vote them out on November
3rd, he will likely succeed at triggering
at least some investigation of his political
enemies. He will get away with all of it.
As far as John Bolton, I hope it's clear to
him he has one choice. It's not even really
a choice when there's only one. He has to
spill the beans period. As far as love Parness.
I hope he publishes everything he has, including
every video he has access to, but in the meantime,
this authoritarian nightmare has to be stopped
one way or the other and there's really no
the other right now. The one way is vote him
out overwhelmingly on November 3rd
because nothing else is having any effect.
Let me know what you think. I'm on Twitter
at the Pacman. Make sure you're following
you there.